dans ma dernière vidéo je vous avais
parlé des conseils santé à ne surtout
pas suivre et à la fin je vous avais
promis un truc je vous donne rendez-vous
la semaine prochaine ici même dans une
vidéo dans laquelle je vais vous donner
mes petits tips pour vous éviter de vous
faire avoir ça vous va ça comme je n'ai
qu'une parole et que je suis super sympa
et ben voilà on y est c'est c'est
aujourd'hui la semaine dernière on a
parlé de sauna vaginale de bougie
d'oreilles de bain d'oxygène et de
lavement au café j'aurais pu aussi vous
parler du spray coca noyau d'avocat pour
soulager les douleurs articulaires ou du
bone smashing qui consiste à se donner
des coups avec différents objets pour
provoquer des fractures des os et se
remodeler le visage ne faites pas ça he
ça marche pas c'est dangereux et c'est
surtout complètement con j'aurais pu
aussi vous parler du mouth tapping se
scotcher la bouche pour se forcer à
respirer par le nez la nuit et du coup
pour mieux dormir c'est inutile c'est
dangereux vous allez juste réussir à
vous arracher la bouche avec le scotch
et puis bon accessoirement c'est jamais
une bonne idée de se boucher un truc par
lequel on respire est-ce que j'ai
vraiment besoin de vous dire que prendre
des médicaments réservés au diabétiqu
pour maigrir c'est la pieridée parce que
c'est dangereux et parce que quand on
n'est pas malade on laisse les
médicaments à ceux qu' ont vraiment
besoin est-ce que c'est vraiment
nécessaire de préciser que non
s'injecter du curcuma dans les veines ça
ne guérit pas le cancer le curcuma oui
le l'épice alors juste 2 secondes
premier petit tips vous avez vu la
gueule du site ça vous inspire confiance
ça et celui-là alors oui on dirait qu'on
est sur le site du monde si on regarde
vite fait mais vous avez vu là les liens
pas clicable et l'URL vous avez vu l'URL
un peu voilà c'est pas exactement
leemonde.fr et l'idée derrière tout ça
c'est au final de réussir à te vendre un
spray magique contre plein de trucs à 39
balles quand même mais après avoir
réussi à te faire croire que tu avais eu
50 % de réduction exceptionnelle voilà
donc si on regarde bien si on s'y
connaît un petit peu on repère vite les
trucs qui sont soit des mauvaises idées
en matière de santé soit carrément des
arnaques soit des trucs un petit peu
douteux qui mérite quand même qu'on se
renseigne un peu avant donc ce que je
vous propose aujourd'hui c'est de vous
donner mes petits tips pour repérer les
fameux conseils santé à ne surtout pas
suivre ah oui juste un petit truc avant
de commencer cette vidéo est sponsorisée
par skill share vous connaissez
peut-être déjà si vous me suivez
régulièrement et si vous me suivez pas
régulièrement bah sachez que ça me fait
beaucoup de peine ils ont déjà
sponsorisé plusieurs de mes vidéos ce
qui est sympa de leur part en tout cas
si vous connaissez pas ou que vous avez
pas encore essayé skill cher c'est une
plateforme de cours en ligne des cours
en vidéo ça veut dire que le cours
commence à l'heure que tu veux que tu
peux le suivre d'où tu veux dans la la
tenue que tu veux et que tu peux
l'arrêter et le reprendre quand tu veux
déjà ça c'est cool mais en plus les
cours sont donnés par des gens qui
connaissent vraiment bien leur sujet
tout est sous-titré en français et il y
en a pour tous les goûts donc il y en a
pour les tiens de goût tu peux apprendre
comment lancer ta boutique sur ets
choper des bases pour savoir dessiner
apprendre à utiliser Photoshop et cetera
et cetera que ce soit pour un projet pro
ou pour un truc créatif que tu as envie
d'apprendre ou de développer tu vas
trouver un cours qui te plaît moi par
exemple cette fois je vais suivre le
cours pour apprendre à faire des photos
cool avec un iPhone parce que je suis
toujours obligé d'en prendre 1000 pour
qu'il y en ait une bonne donc et pour
que vous aussi vous puissiez trouver des
cours qui vous plaisent j'offre un mois
d'abonnement gratuit à skill cher aux
500 premières personnes qui cliqueront
sur le lien que je vous ai mis en
description vous aurez accès à tous les
cours autant que vous voulez pendant
cette période c'est cadeaux ça me fait
plaisir bon il y a plusieurs cas de
figure en fonction du type de conseil en
fonction de la manière dont il est
arrivé jusqu'à vous et cetera et
évidemment ça peut pas être exhaustif
mais vous allez voir qu'il y a quand
même deux trois réflexes à choper déjà
si vous tomber sur un TikTok ou sur une
vidéo quelle qu'elle soit ou même sur
quelqu'un à la télé qui parle d'un
traitement ou d'une technique santé
bien-être et cetera posez-vous ces
questions qui est cette personne qui me
parle là c'est quoi sa compétence c'est
quoi sa légitimité à me parler de ça
est-ce qu'elle est crédible en gros et
puis surtout pourquoi elle me dit ça
c'est quoi ses intentions est-ce qu'elle
est en train juste de me donner des
infos ou est-ce qu'elle est en train de
me dire des trucs pour me convaincre
d'acheter un truc pour ma santé ça c'est
un bon début et puis pu après il y a
d'autres petits trucs à repérer des fois
rien qu'à leur façon de parler et au
mots qu'ils utilisent on a des indices
assez fiables sur la crédibilité des
gens les les cellules cancérigeuses
cancérigeuses c'est mi cancérigène mi
férugineuse je pense mais parfois c'est
plus compliqué parce que le discours il
est déguisé en discours scientifique on
appelle ça un discours pseudocientifique
c'est des belles phrases avec des mots
qui existent et tout c'est pas toujours
si facile de ser trouver mais justement
je vais vous donner deux ou trois mots à
repérer des mots ou des expressions qui
doivent vous mettre la puce à l'oreille
au moins vous poussez à vous interroger
sur ce qu'on est en train de vous
raconter déjà le côté les médecins le
détestent vous avez déjà vu ça non et en
fait c'est pas vendu en France ni en
Europe parce que c'est interdit ils
veulent pas c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant pour eux que vous ayz à
l'hôpital et que vous payez une blinde
ah il est encore là lui ce fameux truc
les médecins ne veulent pas que vous le
sachiez franchement il y a pas assez de
gens pour soigner tout le monde on
manque de médecins et de soignants de
partout vous croyez vraiment que s'il y
avait des traitements qui marche sur des
trucs super graves ou super chiants et
cetera on vous le cacherait pour pas
perdre des patientes et des patients
même sans parler de l'aspect moral et
pourtant il y aura des trucs à dire
est-ce que vous croyez vraiment que les
médecins du monde entier ils se sont mis
d'accord pour dire ok ce truc ça marche
trop bien il faut vraiment que personne
soit au courant que ça existe et comment
ça se passe d'ailleurs ils font
régulièrement des réunions genre à
chaque fois qu'il y a un nouveau
traitement magique alors autre question
est-ce que vous préférez croire une
poignée de personnes là même si dans
l'eau il y a deux trois scientifiques en
mal de célébrité ou la communauté
scientifique mondiale toute entière je
vous laisse
décider bref autre mot dont il faut vous
méfier tout ce qui est naturel naturel
ça veut absolument rien dire l'eau
j'adore l'eau c'est naturel et c'est
garanti 100 % sans effets secondaires
mais l'eau ça ne guérit rien ah si la
déshydratation et ben yes bien joué
Einstein mais en fait un principe actif
c'est-à-dire le truc qui soigne hein que
ce soit dans une plante ou dans un
médicament de synthèse bah ça peut
toujours potentiellement avoir des
effets secondaires parfois c'est minime
parfois le risque est plus grand et plus
le traitement est puissant plus il y a
de risque mais c'est aussi valable pour
un médicament acheté dans une pharmacie
que pour un truc ramassé dans la nature
et pour prendre l'exemple inverse de
l'eau si vous donnez à quelqu'un une
décoocction d'amanite phaloïde c'est 100
% naturel hein mais par contre c'est 100
% mortel donc l'argument naturel égal
efficace et ou sans danger il tient pas
une seconde dans un autre ordre d'idée
méfiance avec tout ce qui contient le
mot détox ou toxine dans les deux cas
les toxines et le fait de détoxifier
c'est des trucs qui existent vraiment
mais c'est des mots qui ont très très
souvent été récupérés par des gens qui
veulent juste vous vendre des produits
qui n'ont aucun effet bénéfique sur
votre santé justement parce que c'est
des mots qui sonnent sérieux qui sonnent
scientifiqu et que il y a une grande
partie des gens qui savent pas vraiment
ce que ça veut dire les toxines par
exemple c'est juste des substances
toxiques on en a dans le corps hein soit
parce qu'on en avale soit parce qu'on en
respire soit parce que à l'intérieur de
nous il y a des germes qui en produisent
mais c'est pas une cure de jus de fruits
ou de thé ou ou de je sais pas quoi qui
va nous les faire éliminer on est équipé
pour ça on a des organes qui servent
exactement à ça et le seul truc qu'on
peut faire pour les aider à faire ça nos
organes bah c'est de pas trop se coller
de substances toxiques dans le corps
c'est tout un autre mot qui doit vous
faire tiquer c'est le mot Booster ou
booster oh vous avez les trucs miracles
qui boostent le système immunitaire ou
qui booste la sécrétion de telle ou
telle hormone voilà donc booster déjà
c'est pas un terme scientifique mais
c'est pas tellement ça le problème le
problème c'est que c'est un terme qui
est purement marketing et qui est là
pour vous faire croire que ce truc que
vous allez faire ce truc que vous allez
prendre ça va avoir un effet immédiat et
ultra efficace est-ce que vous croyez
vraiment qu'on connaît des produits
comme ça qui agissent immédiatement qui
sont hyper efficaces qui sont sans
danger et que personne ne serait au
courant alors attention le terme booster
parfois il peut être utilisé pour parler
de trucs qui sont très sérieux justement
parce que à force de l'entendre un peu
partout bah on se dit que ça finit par
parler aux gens donc c'est pas du 100 %
mais quand même creusez un peu si
l'argument qu'on vous donne pour vous
convaincre c'est ça bouge boost un truc
vous avez compris au-delà des mots ce
qui est important c'est de repérer ce
que les gens en font sils utilisent un
mot vaguement scientifique ou un mot
comme ça avec beaucoup d'impact pour
essayer de vous convaincre que le truc
qui vous propose ça marche hyper bien ça
marche hyper vite voir les deux ça sent
pas bon déjà d'ailleurs ça aussi c'est
un truc qui doit vous alerter dans le
discours de quelqu'un qui vous donne un
conseil santé les trucs hyper rapides
perdre du poids régler un problème de
santé et cetera ça prend du temps il
faut trouver la cause faut trouver le
truc qui marche dessus sans aggraver un
de vos problèmes de santé à vous
personnellement il faut équilibrer le
traitement sans arrêt trouver le bon
dosage faut attendre que le traitement
agisse et cetera et cetera les produits
miracle qui marche sur tout quelle que
soit la cause et cetera et qui agissent
hyper vite ça n'existe pas globalement
méfiez-vous des trucs qu' on l'air
magique comme ça après des fois les
conseils de santé c'est pas une personne
qui s'adresse à vous comme ça oralement
directement qui vous les donne vous
pouvez vous retrouver à cliquer sur une
pub parce qu'il y a un truc qui a l'air
vraiment miraculeux par exemple vous
voyez sûrement de quoi je veux parler il
y a des pubs comme ça un petit peu
partout maintenant parce que les sites
confient la vente de leurs espaces
publicitaires à à des gens qui veulent
juste faire du profit et qui du coup
parfois bah refilent les espaces à des
gens qui sont vraiment pas du tout
fiables donc si vous cliquez sur un truc
comme ça premier réflexe à avoir regarde
un petit peu la tronche qu' a le site
sur lequel vous arrivez le design par
exemple les liens comme on a vu tout à
l'heure là sur le faux site du monde et
puis vous allez voir souvent sur ce
genre de site l'URL l'adresse en haut là
elle est hyper longue la fininte ça va
être de supprimer tout ce qu' a après
le. com le pointfr ou le point ce que
vous voulez histoire d'arriver sur la
page d'accueil du site et si vous tombez
sur un truc comme ça par exemple ça sent
pas très bon 2ième truc soyez curieux
googlez le nom des marques euh le nom
des médicaments le nom des médecins qui
sont cités le nom des experts des
témoins et cetera voilà vérifier que
tout ça ça existe et si c'est le cas
vous pouvez aussi vérifier les avis
ensuite même truc que pour le reste dont
on a parlé tout à l'heure est-ce que ça
utilise la rhtorique de nous on sait un
truc hyper secret hyper efficace mais
que les puissants ne veulent surtout pas
que vous vous sachiez donc du coup si
vous nous croyez bah c'est que vous êtes
vraiment super intelligent blab bla bla
blab bla bla quand on propose un vrai
traitement on n pas besoin de manipuler
les gens comme ça et pareil comme tout à
l'heure si on vous propose des trucs
magiques gardez à l'esprit que la magie
ça n'existe pas ça ça n'existe pas quand
on a une calvici les cheveux ne
repoussent pas en 28 jours comme ça hein
encore moins en 8 minutes d'ailleurs le
facteur temps c'est aussi un bon indice
d'arnaque si on vous promet des trucs en
un temps hyper court ça pue autre
exemple par exemple non on ne se
débarrasse pas du GR du ventre en une
semaine ah oui la syntaxe aussi c'est un
bon indicateur de sérieux l'orthographe
aussi alors s'il y a les deux dans la
même phrase en gros si vous voyez une
pub pour un truc qui vous propose de
vous débarrasser d'un truc qui vous
complexe oui parce que bien sûr ils sont
malins hein ils savent comment avoir
votre attention déjà et puis comment
vous faire baisser un petit peu votre
garde et si on vous propose une solution
hyper simple et hyper rapide c'est une
arnaque je précise c'est un doigt avec
de la pommade dessus hein vous aviez vu
autre chose non pour résumer quand c'est
trop beau pour être vrai
c'est parce que c'est pas vrai quand
c'est un truc super secret hyper bien
caché ça n'existe pas donc prenez le
temps juste de checker un ou deux trucs
avant de suivre un conseil santé ça
marche pour pas mal d'autres trucs aussi
d'ailleurs voilà DTC c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien